Speaker 1: All right, we had a bunch of
interesting stuff happen over the weekend,
I want to start with a rally that took place
in Cullman, Alabama. This is a relevant rally
for two or three different reasons. Number
one, this is sort of the start of the 2022
election. It's it seems to be getting going
this early. Mo Brooks is running in Alabama.
Donald Trump flew in. It was an all day rally
and Donald Trump showing up there in the midst
of bad weather and chaos and lies and delusions
in support of Mo Brooks. Also relevant was this
rally because of all the people who, of course,
delusional, who believed that Donald Trump was
going to be reinstated as president during August.
This is likely to be Donald Trump's last public
appearance in August unless some other rally
gets scheduled for this last week or 10 days,
eight days that's left of August. And
there was the belief among some and
I mean, obviously, this is ridiculous, but there
was the belief among some that at this rally,
Donald Trump was going to be reinstated
as president. One such reason why some
believe that was that CEO of my pillow, Michael
Lyndell, who I interviewed a couple of weeks ago,
was at this rally and why that would make anyone
think there's going to be a reinstatement like
it. None of it makes sense. I'm telling you
the reasons why people who don't know anything
thought maybe Trump would be reinstated. I'll
cut to the chase. He was not. But let's get into
some of these clips from this rally. It's a very
repetitive speech. Donald Trump was very confused
and dishonest. And we're going to look at a number
of different moments. But the most notable moment
and we're going to dove into this a little bit
later is that Donald Trump was booed by his own
sycophantic followers when he casually said, hey,
guys, the vaccine is good. And Trump immediately
having to backtrack and say, no, it's OK, it's OK.
You've got your freedoms. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: Three days, less than nine months. And
it's great. And you know what? I believe totally
in your freedoms. I do agree. You do what you
have to do, but I recommend take the vaccines.
I did it. It's good. Take the vaccines.
But you got to. That's OK. It's all wrong.
Speaker 1: And then the gearing starts freedoms.
Speaker 2: But I happen to take the vaccine.
If it doesn't work, you'll be the first to know.
Speaker 1: OK, that is really something. I mean,
that is sort of like when you train a protection
dog to be so aggressive that it even starts being
dangerous to the owner. The owner has to get rid
of the dog because the dog meant to protect him
is too. It's too aggressive. It's too dangerous.
I think this is the first time that a rally crowd
of Trump's actually booed him. I think they
boo when he gets them to boost someone else
when he says something about Hillary or Biden or
whatever. But I can't remember another time where
they actually booed Donald Trump. A lot of the
stuff during the rally was kind of the typical
stuff. Donald Trump claiming that the election
was stolen and that very soon you're going to
see the evidence coming out. We've been waiting
for months. I mean, will any of us still be alive
when that evidence comes out? Take a listen to
Speaker 2: one of the first acts that Biden did
after Mitch McConnell said we must get back
to work. We have to get our country going.
We have to approve him as the president. Even
though the evidence was staggering. You'll see
the evidence starting to come out. It's
already come out far beyond what we need,
by the way, far, far, far beyond what we do.
Speaker 1: And yet it hasn't seemed to work
to put Trump back in the office
because this is all a grift.
Speaker 2: We have to get back to our
country and running our country. Mitch
McConnell. And the first thing Biden did
was sign seventeen of the worst executive
orders in the history of our country.
Speaker 1: Those executive orders actually
were pretty good in that they undid a lot of
the damage that Donald Trump did. Trump then,
you know, as usual, uncovered. He just seems
confused. He weighed in on the Delta variant
and he talked about how he's shaking hands
with everybody and hopefully it doesn't
cause an outbreak. You know, he doesn't now,
Speaker 2: he didn't stop the virus. You know,
they say, oh, he gets wonderful. Martin doesn't
get good marks. He's done a terrible job,
including on vaccinations, including on
everything else. And now the virus is back.
The virus is back. I'm shaking hands with
everybody backstage. I say, well, I don't know,
this is a good thing or a bad. You read about
it in three or four days, maybe. Hopefully not.
Speaker 1: So he seems to acknowledge that
sometimes when he does these big events
and he's hanging out with people and shaking
hands, it causes spread. And I mean, listen,
we know it happened. Herman Cain, at least in
theory, got sick at a Trump rally and subsequently
died. We don't know that for sure, but the timing
of it certainly suggests that just always very
confused. At a certain point during this event,
Trump shifted over into what we might call foreign
policy. Now you might hear this and say, David,
that's not really foreign policy. What I mean
is he mentioned foreign countries. And when it
comes to Trump, that's as close to foreign policy
as we're ever going to get. Listen to this and
Speaker 2: have weakness in the White House.
They have to respect your president. When
I was president, we only had strength.
Remember the 59 shots we took in Syria?
Speaker 1: Now, remember those 59 shots
at Syria? That's the bombing of the runway
that he let Russia know about ahead of time,
which was cleared and then reopened within 24
hours. That's the and I'm not an advocate of
bombing. I'm just saying even Trump projecting
strength on that. It was pretty pathetic.
Speaker 2: Fifty nine missiles, every single one
of them hit that target from seven hundred miles
away. And I was sitting with President Xi of
China. Do you remember having chocolate cake
at Mar a Lago is wonderful cake. And when I said
to him what we had just done, the missiles were
launched, he looked at me and he goes, repeat,
I didn't know he spoke English, actually said,
repeat. I said, what did you just say? Repeat.
So he spoke a little more English than I thought
because he never said hello, but he said repeat.
Speaker 1: So of course, we don't know whether
Trump is saying she said repeat the bombing
or repeat what you said. It's a completely
incoherent story, as are most of these. And
then speaking of foreign policy, maybe one of
the strangest moments of the speech, Donald Trump
claimed that a five year old was advising him on
military issues. That's weird. But I.
Speaker 2: I ask the child,
so what would you do after describing would
you leave the military until everything's out,
including the civilians and all of
that incredible military equipment?
Or would you have the military go out
first? Sure. I'd leave the military when
he was five, he said I'd leave the
military and get everything out first.
I said thank you very much, but they didn't.
Speaker 1: All right. So there it is. A five year
old kid knew exactly what it is that Trump should
be doing. There it is. And then maybe the most
sort of despicable moments were when Donald
Trump started praising and shouting out
complete and total lunatics like Marjorie Taylor
Green, who will talk about a little bit later
and later Mike Pelo, also known as Mike
Lyndell. Let's listen first to him talking
about how great Marjorie Taylor Greene is and
Speaker 2: one of my favorite people. Oh, she's so
smart. I hope she's around. I hope she's around.
She is an incredible woman. She's a brilliant
woman. Does he get credit for it? But we all know
about that stuff. Marjorie Taylor Greene Parrish.
Can you imagine? She's great. She's great.
She's a warrior. She's a warrior. Everything
I said about Georgia is true, but you're right.
Speaker 1: Yeah, and that's really what it's
about. She placates Trump when it comes to his
bogus, baseless, exhausting, tired claims that
actually he won Georgia and not Joe Biden. And
then Trump talking about Mike Pillow, my pillow
CEO, Mike Lyndell. He likes him to be a
Speaker 2: patriot, a wonderful
Speaker 1: man, by the way, a patriot
Speaker 2: who puts his guts into everything,
a man that they don't treat properly. He's
smart. He loves his country so much he's
willing to die for this country. I watched
him over the last week at his symposium,
which was really amazing, some of the people.
Speaker 1: Do we really believe Trump watched that
lunatic symposium? Maybe he did. I don't know that
Speaker 2: we're incredible, incredible people,
Mike, Lyndell, Mike.
Speaker 1: And the crowd loves it.
Yeah, so anyway, another completely
unhinged rally, you know, the weird thing,
we stream this live, the weird thing about Trump
rallies is that the crowd is so sycophantic.
I mean, at this point, they drive out to
the middle of nowhere. It's just a field
in Alabama, thunderstorms. They're there all day
waiting for Trump. Trump's an hour plus late,
as always. And they just they just love the guy.
They love him, love them, love them. And yet,
no one he mentions the vaccine and they boo him.
And we're going to dig into that more because I
think that's a big that's a big thing. But also,
they they very quickly check out and seem bored
at these events. It's this huge, huge buildup.
Maybe it's because they're exhausted by the time
Trump actually comes out. As soon as Trump comes
out to speak, they very quickly lose energy. And
you see people on their phones often you see
couples talking to each other and checking
the time. You can tell they're talking
about how long are we really going to stay?
This is sort of going nowhere. It's almost
Castro. Like he's not going six hours, but
sometimes going two hours talking about
nothing. It's a very weird thing, which
shouldn't surprise us, because after all, these
are the people we'd expect to see at these events